Vladimir Putin just met with the North
Korean leader Kim Jong-un and while the
details are officially secret it's
pretty clear that they were making a
deal about weapons so why would Russia a
large military superpower need to buy
weapons from a tiny poor isolated
country in Asia well it turns out North
Korea invests a lot in weapons and ammo
and a lot of their weapons are based off
of Soviet designs which Russia's are as
well so as Russia continues its war in
Ukraine it's using lots of ammo
specifically these artillery shells and
they're running low hence asking North
for more in exchange Russia might give
North Korea some of its missile
technology which would be a pretty big
deal and help North Korea continue to
arm itself to the teeth to scare away
its enemies all of this shows just how
serious Vladimir Putin is in rejecting
the Western lead order and doing his own
thing with other Outcast countries if
you want to better understand global
politics follow for more